Uh,
this week we're going to talk about renal physiology.
So renal is kidney physiology,
the study of the,
uh,
the function of a kidneys.
And we're going to talk mainly about how they work,
when they're working correctly and what functions they perform in the,
in the body.
And,
uh,
you probably know,
that there,
uh,
important.
Uh,
but,
uh,
hopefully by the end of the lecture today you'll know exactly why they are so
important for your overall state of health.
And,
um,
and you,
you won't live very long without a near normal kidney function.
And,
um,
the,
the reading on this is chapter nine and in section we'll talk about a,
uh,
biomedical engineering innovation,
that over the last 50 or 60 years or so has really changed,
uh,
changed the quality and duration of life for patients that have kidney disease.
And that's kidney dialysis or renal dialysis.
So we'll talk about that on Thursday afternoon.
So this is just an outline of the things that we're going to cover.
Uh,
during the,
during the lecture today and on Thursday we're going to talk about sort of just
gross aspects of the urinary system,
uh,
the kidney,
the bladder,
and the tubes that connect these things.
I'll talk a little bit about the differences between plasma.
Plasma is the fluid that circulates in your body.
And we thought about a circulation of fluids in the body the week before spring
break.
Uh,
we talked about the heart and the blood vessels in the and the blood.
And so the main fluid of interest there was plasma.
This,
this fluid that blood cells circulate in the main fluid will be interested in,
in renal physiology,
his urine.
And this is a fluid that's produced by the kidneys,
stored in the bladder and then excrete it from the body.
And it's one of the primary mechanisms that your body has for getting rid of
waste and regulating the composition of fluids like plasma.
Okay.
Um,
and we'll,
I'll talk a little bit more about that in just a second,
uh,
to,
to understand how it works.
We'll talk about the anatomy of the kidney on the gross level and on the
microscopic level.
And it has an amazingly sophisticated organization,
which is critical for its function.
So if you understand the anatomy of the kidney,
you understand a lot about how it works.
And then we'll talk about specifics about how urine is created in the kidney and
processed.
And um,
and um,
it turns out that all of these processes are important for maintaining your
health.
And as I mentioned,
we'll talk lastly about about dialysis,
which is a extraordinarily effective but not quite perfect means,
uh,
for,
for um,
keeping people that have kidney failure in good health.
So I've shown you a picture like this,
maybe exactly this picture,
a picture like this before,
but this is sort of a,
a,
a block diagram or an engineering view of the human body.
And so you can see the outside world is the things that surround this red and
blue labeled,
uh,
box and the inside of the body is inside.
We talked last time we were here,
we talked about the circulatory system.
And so this mechanism for circulating fluids around in the body,
and we talked about how that works and why that's so important.
You'll remember that when we talked about the nervous system,
which uh,
which controls a lot of body functions.
We talked about both in the nervous system and the cardiovascular system,
how important certain ions were for the function of those cells.
In particular,
we talked about sodium and potassium,
sodium and potassium,
which are present in the case of sodium at high concentration outside of cells,
low concentration inside potassium,
the reverse high concentration inside low concentration outside.
In order for those cells to function for a nerve cell to send a signal down an
Axon or for a cardiac muscle cell to a contract,
those concentrations of ions have to be present,
right?
And they have to be the way that I described,
you have to have high extracellular sodium,
low intercellular,
hi intracellular potassium,
low extra cellular.
All right?
So if your sodium and potassium levels are not correct,
you can't make an action potential in the way that we described before.
Heart doesn't beat brains,
can't send signals,
right?
So all of that physiology we talked about in the nervous system and the heart
depends on having ion concentrations in your body at the correct level.
So how is that maintained?
Well,
one way you could make do,
you could think about if you have a box like this,
if this is your body,
you could think about maintaining it by just knowing exactly how much sodium and
potassium to eat every day so that you always keep the right amount,
you know you're going to lose some,
you lose some fluids.
So if you knew exactly how much to eat,
you could regulate concentration that way,
but that would be,
that's difficult to do.
Right?
And we,
and you know,
we don't do that.
We eat in general excess sodium and excess potassium.
So somehow our body is keeping these concentrations at the right level.
How does it do that?
Well,
that's really the main function of the kidney.
The main function of the kidney is to sense how much sodium and potassium there
is in your body.
And then to extract the amount that's not needed in order to maintain the levels
at the constant concentration.
That's needed,
right?
So the main function of the urinary system,
which is shown as this part of the diagram over here,
is to detect what's in the plasma,
what's in the blood,
and think about it in terms of sodium and potassium concentrations.
But there are many,
many other elements that are also controlled.
So it detects what's there and it removes what's not needed.
That is it.
It removes what is in excess of what you need to have the proper concentration,
right?
Um,
now you could imagine doing that in two ways.
Let's just think about sodium concentrations for,
for if your sodium concentration is too high,
right?
Too High,
so it needs to come down,
then the kidney could either excrete more sodium or excrete less water,
right?
And you know that the kidney gets rid of waste by getting rid of urine.
And urine is mostly water,
right?
And so you can control concentration in the body by either changing how much of
the molecule you keep or how much water you retain or how much water you lose,
right?
And so all of these things are linked together in some way.
The kidneys set here in intimate contact with the circulatory system.
We'll talk about that.
In order to perform this function of regulating concentrations of things in the
blood,
it needs to see a lot of blood.
And so blood flow to the kidney as essential.
And you'll see that it's anatomy,
puts it in a good position to see a lot of the blood flow.
And then it does some transformations.
It does some functions we'll talk about over the course of the next couple of
days.
It then produces a fluid called urine.
You have a reservoir for urine in your body called the bladder.
That's basically just a storage vessel for urine that's produced by the kidneys.
And then you excrete that and what's in that excluded,
flew and urine,
mainly water,
salts and organic ways.
Now what organic ways are,
uh,
are uh,
eliminated by the kidneys.
Well,
think about metabolism,
right?
You're breaking down sugars,
you're breaking down proteins,
you're using those raw materials to build other molecules.
But there are waste products of that process of breaking down and building
backup molecules.
So the the a waste product of sugar metabolism,
you know is carbon dioxide,
right?
Where does the the,
the,
the final form of carbon in the body is carbon dioxide and you get rid of that.
Not In the kidney largely,
but mainly in the lung by breathing out co two,
right.
The main product of nitrogen metabolism and where does nitrogen come from comes
from proteins that we eat and in the Western world and develop worlds.
We eat a lot more protein than we for building new proteins.
We have protein rich diets and so you have a lot of waste products from proteins
that accumulate.
In particular the waste product of nitrogen and all amino acids have nitrogen.
The end product of metabolism of amino acids or proteins is a molecule called
urea and so your Reia is,
that is an example of an abundant organic waste that's eliminated by the
kidneys.
It's not volatile.
It's not a gas like carbon dioxide,
so you can't breathe it out.
It has to be eliminated in water and it's concentrated in the urine.
If concentrations of your REIA get too high and you're in your plasma,
it becomes toxic,
right?
And so one of the main functions of the kidney is to get rid of end products of
nitrogen metabolism like urea to keep the level low enough that they don't cause
any toxicity.
Okay?
So that's,
that's a couple of,
as you can see now,
very important functions for the kidney,
getting rid of a waste product of natural metabolism that would otherwise be
toxic to the body,
that's urea and regulating the concentrations of ions like sodium and potassium.
And we could add calcium and phosphate and magnesium,
but regulating the concentrations primarily of sodium and potassium,
uh,
so that the other organs in your body can function in the right way.
And we call that,
uh,
we call that function.
Maintaining the internal environment,
maintaining the internal mill,
you maintaining the internal fluid composition at some constant level so that
the other organs can function properly.
Okay,
so let's think about the a anatomy a little bit and it's shown on this slide,
the words at the top of the slide.
Just tell you what I,
what I already told you,
you know,
uh,
probably that your kidneys,
you have two of them,
um,
and uh,
one on the left and one on the right and they set sort of right below your rib
cage in the back there in the back part of your abdominal cavity of space.
It's called the Retroperitoneale,
uh,
a position in your body.
And if you remember from the circulatory system,
the heart is right here,
right?
The heart is in the center,
slightly to the left side of the chest and coming out of the heart,
the cardiac output comes out through the aorta and the aorta is initially
directed upwards,
right?
And then it,
and then it curves and goes down through the abdomen here.
So if I trace the path of the aorta,
it starts in the thorax,
you know,
between the lungs,
moves down here,
crosses through the diaphragm and into the abdominal space.
So this is the abdominal aorta and you can see that the kidneys are positioned
on either side of the abdominal aorta.
Now the,
the,
the flow through the abdominal aorta is quite high.
This is one of the main vessels,
right?
And there are some branch points before him there.
So there's some blood that goes up to the head and the upper parts of the body,
but the,
but the major portion of the cardiac output flows down your abdominal aorta.
And there are two main branches off the abdominal aorta right here called the
renal arteries and the renal arteries feed blood to the kidneys directly.
So the kidney is in a great anatomical position to receive a lot of the blood
flow.
And it does is my very minute to minute,
depending on your state of health and your level of activity.
Uh,
but it receives on average about 25% of the cardiac output.
Cardiac output was,
you remember what the cardiac output number was,
a good number to keep in your head,
five liters per minute.
And so it's receiving over one liter per minute of blood.
Each of the kidneys are so that,
that's a lot.
Um,
if blood goes in,
blood has to come back out.
It comes back out through to a renal veins,
one from each kidney,
uh,
which carries the blood back to the Vena Cava and then back up to the heart.
So the kidney is in a privileged position with respect to the circulatory system
so that it can receive a lot of the flow.
The,
the uh,
the blood vessels aren't shown on this diagram because I wanted to make it clear
in this diagram,
what are the,
uh,
the all the components of the urinary system,
but you can see the renal artery.
This is a blowup of the kidney over here across sections.
So you could see inside the kidney is not surprisingly kidney shaped,
kidney shaped.
And um,
and so it kind of wraps around this central core.
And in the central core,
here's the renal artery,
which is bringing blood in.
The one labeled for here,
the renal vein,
which is taking blood out is labeled number five.
And inside that renal artery splits into many smaller arteries,
which split,
which spread this blood flow throughout the,
the,
uh,
the bulk of the kidney,
right?
The renal vein carries a blood back out
and back to the Vena cave.
As I mentioned.
Now there's one other vessel which emerges from this,
uh,
bless you.
That emerges from this,
uh,
from this section of the kidney.
And this is called the uritor labeled number six here.
And this is the vessel through which urine flows
and that your in flows out of the kidney.
And then down down you can see this uritor one from each kidney flowing down
into this sac called the bladder.
That's the bladder.
And then the bladder has another vessel which,
uh,
which connects to the outside world called the urethra.
So urine is produced kit continuously by the kidneys.
Urine is continuously flowing,
although the rate might change with time,
it's continually flowing into the bladder.
The bladder is an expandable reservoir.
It expands,
collects urine until you're ready to release it,
right?
And then it's released through the urethra to the external environment.
So you have a picture of the anatomy.
There are a couple of functions I didn't talk about and we won't talk about
really,
uh,
in,
our,
our time on this subject.
The kidney also has a very important function in regulating blood pressure.
And we won't talk about that.
It also secretes some hormones,
uh,
that,
that uh,
um,
aid in a red blood cell production.
So there are some other functions aside from the ones we talked about,
but I'm going to talk about the main ones I've emphasized already.
Okay.
So you have a picture,
uh,
for,
for the anatomy of the kidneys and where they sit.
And you will remember that for each kidney.
Now we'll just assume that they're each identical for the rest of our discussion
today.
And for each kidney,
there's blood coming in,
there's blood going out and there's urine coming out.
And so one way,
and we've talked about this a little bit before,
but if you were an engineer just trying to analyze this system,
our question was how does the kidney do what it does,
right?
One way to try to understand what it does is to,
is to treat it very simply.
Let's just say it's a,
it's a black box.
I don't really know anything about what goes on inside.
What I know about is that there are flows going in and out.
There's the renal artery that flows in,
there's the renal vein that flows out and there's the ureter which can,
which carries urine away.
And let's just look at what goes in and what comes out and see what we could
learn about the function of the organ or what it must do just by looking at
those at those inputs and outputs.
And this is a common mode of engineering analysis.
So if we looked more carefully at what's flowing into the kidney,
there's a blood and at flows through,
and I mentioned a lot of blood goes through the kidney.
The astonishing rate,
uh,
that,
each of your two kidneys received 1700 liters of blood per day,
which flows continuously,
uh,
from the aorta into the renal arteries of that,
you know,
the blood is composed of blood cells and plasma.
So if we just looked at the plasma,
about half of that volume,
slightly more than half of that volume is plasma,
right?
What's in plasma?
Mainly water proteins like albumin and antibodies and salts like sodium and
potassium bicarbonate.
And waste products like urea.
So if we measured what the concentration was,
the average concentration of each of those things in the renal arteries,
we could calculate how much flows in every day.
And so plasma 950 liters per day.
So that's nine,
that's almost a thousand liters of water per day,
right?
Flows through your kidneys.
Um,
a 133 milli moles of,
uh,
of sodium per day.
Uh,
less potassium per day because there's less potassium,
right?
Concentrations,
sodium high potassium is low,
and the extra cellular fluid,
a lot of bicarbonate,
the main Ph buffer in the blood,
and quite a lot of urea 500 grams of urea.
And remember,
this is a waste product,
so your body needs to get rid of this.
So that's what's flowing in to each kidney.
What comes out,
we could think about analyzing by looking at what comes out in the urine.
And so if we collected the urine and measured the concentrations,
what comes out is about 1.5 liters per day of water,
of fluid volume.
Uh,
what comes out in terms of sodium,
about 103 millimoles per day.
So of the hundred and 30,
3000 millimoles of sodium that go through the kidneys each day,
your,
uh,
kidney gets rid of about a hundred millimoles,
right?
So it's looking at a lot of sodium,
figuring out how much you need and then excluding the little bit of excess that
you have because of excess that comes in in your diet.
Generally we eat more salt than we need to keep alive,
right?
Uh,
with a potassium,
uh,
50 millimoles per day.
So it's still a small fraction of what comes through by carbonate.
Small fraction of what comes through.
And urea.
Now there's a lot,
right?
52,
uh,
compared to 475.
All right,
so,
um,
so a sizable fraction of the urea gets eliminated every day.
Now these numbers that are percentages over here,
what I did was I just took the total amount that you eliminate the total amount
that's eliminated.
So 1.5 liters per day and figured out what percentage that was of the total
water that the kidney sees every day.
So 1.5 liters per day is 0.16% of 950 liters per day.
So your,
you,
your,
your kidney excretes 0.1% 0.16% of the water that flows through it,
a pretty small fraction,
but,
and,
and a similar small fraction of sodium,
more of potassium,
much less of bicarbonate,
and 11% of the urea that goes through.
So how could the kidney do this?
Right?
How did the kidney do this?
And you know,
something,
how does the kidney work?
How does it,
okay,
how does it,
how does it separate the molecules that it wants to excrete from all the
molecules that are passing through here?
So what must this look like inside in order to accomplish this task?
And you can learn a lot about it just by looking at these numbers.
How does it work?
Yeah.
Osmosis or,
okay,
what's Osmosis?
Okay.
Right.
So it's um,
it's uh,
osmosis is separation across some membrane where you have a semipermeable
membrane and that's a good,
that's a good idea.
Um,
there,
there is osmosis that goes on and we're going to talk about it.
Now.
Last Moses is a really critical,
uh,
way that the kidney functions at the microscopic level and we'll uh,
we'll talk about that.
Um,
but there's,
there's another sort of more cruder level of function that I'm thinking about.
A simpler level of function.
How do you,
what was your vision of how the kidney works when you came in here?
What is your kidney do?
Filters.
Yeah,
it's a filter,
right?
How do filters work?
How does it filter work?
Yeah,
so,
so a filter works because it has some property that if you put a liquid on top
of it,
some of the components of the liquid will pass through and some of them won't.
And generally we think about filters.
What physical principle does it use to keep things on one side or to decide what
passes through?
Yeah,
what,
what property of molecules size generally filters work based on size.
There are mechanical and they have holes in them and those holes are of a
certain size and so only molecules that are smaller than that size can pass
through,
right?
So now,
now that would make sense for the kidney because what's in the,
what's in the blood that you don't want to pass through?
You don't want blood cells to pass through and those are large,
right?
Those are,
those are five or 10 microns in diameter.
You don't want those to pass through.
So let's have a filter that keeps blood cells on one side and only allows,
uh,
things that are smaller than blood cells to go through.
You also have,
um,
proteins in your blood and those are generally large molecules,
right?
You have albumin,
you got the antibodies,
you have lots of lipid proteins,
you have lot,
you have insulin,
you have lots of proteins that are in the blood.
And those have important functions inside your body.
They're hard to make,
you don't want to lose them.
And in general,
the filter is,
uh,
such that proteins don't go through.
Small Molecules can go through,
glucose can go through,
it's this much smaller molecule.
But do you want glucose to go through?
In fact,
I haven't even listed it here.
I have d.
What'd you want glucose to go through?
Probably not because you,
I mean you worked hard to gather your food and eat it and you want to extract
the energy from glucose.
Uh,
you don't want to lose a lot of it,
so you'd like to keep that in.
But it's a small molecule.
In fact,
it's not so much bigger than a urea or sodium or potassium or by carbon at these
are all the,
these are all fairly small molecules.
They all pass very easily through the filter.
So if your kidney was just a filter,
what would you expect to see in the,
in the,
uh,
okay.
In,
in the urine in particular,
what would these percentages be?
If the kidney act as a filter?
If I tell you that all of these molecules are smaller.
Okay.
Are small enough to pass freely through the kidney filter?
Yeah.
Sorry.
Percent higher or,
or
sorry.
Willmon did you say?
Well,
they'd all be the same,
right?
They,
they'd all be the same percentage.
If the kidney was just a filter and everything passed through that was smaller
than a certain amount,
then then what you should see in the urine is just the same exact same
percentage in the urine as is in the plasma,
right.
If your kidney was just a filter and it just allowed urea and bicarbonate and
potassium and sodium and water to pass through,
then you should have the same fraction of water,
blah,
blah.
These percentages wouldn't be different.
They'd be whatever they needed to be.
Now,
what's the most important thing here?
Getting rid of the toxic compound.
Got To get rid of the toxic compound.
Otherwise you get sick.
Right?
So if the kidney was just a filter and I needed to get rid of 11% of the urea,
then I would have to also lose 11% of the water.
Yeah,
right.
And it's simple filter.
If I want to get rid of 11% of the urea and the urea is dissolved in water,
they both pass through the filter that I'd have to get rid of 11% of the water.
So let's say 11% is about a hundred times this,
a hundred times a 0.16%.
So that would mean this number has to be a hundred liters per day.
What's the problem with having a urine output of 100 liters per day?
That's a lot.
And so could you sit through a class that's 50 minutes long?
Probably not.
So,
um,
how is there a one liter bottle get somebody has bottles.
How,
how big is,
that's probably bigger than a leader writer
just about a leader.
So,
um,
so you would p a hundred of those per day.
So your bladder is,
can be a pretty good size,
but,
but it's not big enough to hold a hundred liters.
Right?
Your body is not
that big.
Um,
and,
and so a problem if your kidney was a,
with a simple filter is that you would have to be,
um,
you would have to be losing water screening water all the time.
And the flip side of that is for you not to shrink,
you've got to beat consuming that amount of water.
All right?
So if the kidney was a simple filter and you needed to get rid of urea and
assuming that these numbers are your appropriate numbers for,
then,
uh,
then you would have to,
then you'd have to pee out over a hundred liters per day and you have to drink a
hundred liters of water per day in order to maintain your volume,
right?
Because what happens if you lose too much volume,
then you're ion concentrations go out of whack as well because they're not
dissolved in the right,
uh,
volume of water.
So your kidney must have some other mechanism,
uh,
besides being a filter and in particular it has to recover things that you need,
right?
So filtration is an important part of it,
but it also has to be selective in some way.
And filtration is not selective enough.
Filtration is not selective enough because there are lots of molecules that are
about the same size,
some that are toxic and some that are essential for health and you can't
separate them just based on size.
Um,
just another example of,
of that,
if we looked,
another way to look at how the kidney works is to look at relative
concentrations in the plasma and the urine.
Ordinarily,
the kidney is very,
very good at,
at,
um,
uh,
keeping glucose out of the urine.
Even though it's a small molecule,
it gets filtered,
uh,
along with urea,
the kidney,
uh,
saves it somehow so that it's abnormal to have any urine in your,
any glucose into your urine.
Even though you have high concentrations in the plasma,
you get rid of quite a lot of sodium,
a tremendous amount of urea as we mentioned,
and uh,
create and he has another waste product that turns out to be important for
reasons we won't really talk about very much.
So how does it work if it,
if it,
if,
if it's not just a simple filter,
we'll filtration is an important part of it.
So occurs in the kidney.
It's the initial separation that happens where,
uh,
where,
um,
uh,
molecules that your kidneys processing gets separated from the blood.
Plasma filtration is the important first step.
And we'll talk about that in a few moments.
But this filtration does not directly produce urine.
And you know what the problem with that is?
It's you'd have to produce too much urine if that was the only thing that
happened instead the kidney reabsorbs.
So after the filtration step,
it takes the fluid that's produced by,
uh,
by,
filtration
and it looks at that fluid and it decides what things the body can use.
Water,
glucose,
sodium,
potassium,
and it reabsorbed them back into the blood.
So filtration is the first function.
Reabsorption is the second function.
And if you're filtering a hundred liters per day and you're only creating one
liter of urine,
that means that there's a lot of reabsorption going on,
right?
Most of the water that gets filtered through the kidney gets reabsorbed.
Only that small fraction 0.1% gets,
uh,
gets excreted in urine.
So we're going to call the,
uh,
the,
the filtrate or the fluid that gets produced by filtration.
That's,
that's fluid that wants to be urine,
right?
It once it,
it,
it wants to be your in some day,
but it's,
that's what it aspires to.
It aspires to be your end,
but it's not quite urine yet.
And the important role of the kidney is to make that is to extract back out the
fluids that are in this sort of want to be urine.
The things that it can use to produce a very concentrated,
a waste stream.
The kidney also directly secretes some compounds.
There's some compounds that aren't filtered very effectively or as effectively
as we need them to be.
And so the kidney has mechanisms for taking molecules directly from the blood
and,
and pumping them into the urine.
And that's,
uh,
that's a little,
that's a,
that's a specialized function that's a little bit beyond where we need to go.
I wanted to show it to you for w where we have time to go.
I wanted to show it to you for completion.
If you go on to study
physiology,
uh,
you'll learn a lot about this,
but there's filtration reabsorption.
This accounts for the majority of what happens in terms of processing to form
urine,
but there's also secretion.
And then finally the year end that goes to the bladder and is eliminated.
Um,
okay,
so just coming back to this picture again.
Uh,
the renal arteries,
uh,
about 180 liters of that fluid that comes in per day is filtered.
So this is,
uh,
was about 900 and some leaders of plasma that goes into the kidneys.
Of that 180 liters are filtered,
meaning whatever the filter portion of the kidney is,
180 of those leaders or a fairly substantial fraction passes through the filter.
You only lose about 1.5 liters per day of urine.
And that means that the kidney is reabsorbing 178.5 liters per day,
right?
So that's an astounding amount of work,
both to filter this quantity of fluid and then recover that fluid back takes a
lot of energy and um,
and uh,
we'll see that there's a lot of action that's going on inside the cells of the
kidney to allow this to happen.
Uh,
but you should be very grateful because if your kidney did not do this work for
you,
then there were a lot of activities that you would have trouble participating
in,
right?
If you had to,
if you had to be constantly worried about peeing and drinking,
you couldn't wait to do it,
right?
Cause you've got to do it all the time in order to maintain this balance.
A life would be very different.
Okay.
And this is the problem when the kidneys begin to fail,
if you're not filtering,
secreting and UB reabsorbing this much water,
which the kid needs do through very active energy consuming processes,
then what happens?
Concentration of urea goes up,
concentration of sodium and potassium gets out of whack and your health very
quickly deteriorates.
Alright.
So you cannot live a healthy life very long without all of these things
happening continuously.
Okay.
How does the kidney accomplished these functions?
What it accomplishes it through,
through a a marvelously elegant machine called the nephron.
And a Nephron is the functional unit of the kidney.
And I'm going to show you in a diagram in a moment.
Uh,
this is sort of the,
a picture a cartoon of the kidney.
If you turned it on its side,
right?
It's sitting up this way and it's kidney bean shape and I turned it on its side.
So this part,
the capsule is pointing up that's up here.
And the inner part or the Mandala,
the part where all the,
where all the vessels come in is pointing down and oriented within each,
within each,
um,
each kidney are a million,
over a million of these functional units called nephrons and nephrons are just a
series of tubes that are arranged in a very specific configuration.
And we'll see in the next slide that nephrons look slightly different.
There are nephrons of these million,
there are different populations that look slightly different,
but they all have the same basic anatomy.
And uh,
I'll just trace through the anatomy here,
starting at this little tuft at the top of the nephron or near the top of the
nephron.
So the capsule is a structure called the glomerulus.
And the Marea lists is where the blood carrying tubes and the urine carrying
tubes meet the glow.
The Glow Marea list is where these two sets of Tubules,
meat and the [inaudible] list is the structure in which filtration takes place.
So what you see here is a ball,
which is basically a sack.
And so you imagine a sac that is in closing sort of,
uh,
tuft or tumbleweed of blood vessels.
So there's blood that's coming into this tuft of capillaries and there's blood
that's going out.
You can't really see it here,
but there's blood that's coming in,
this blood that's going out.
Each of these Tufts is really a,
a branch of the renal artery,
right?
I showed you the picture of the renal artery comes in,
it branches at branches,
at branches.
It branches a million times and there are one of one of those million branches
goes to each a glomerulus.
Okay.
And it forms a Tuft of capillaries there.
And this capillary is surrounded by a sack when I better do it the same way.
So not to get into the capillary comes in,
it's surrounded by a sack.
Filtration occurs across these capillary walls.
Yeah.
And how does filtration occur?
Filtration occurs by pressure drop.
Filtration occurs by a pressure drop.
So the same physical force that's moving blood through your circulatory system.
We talked about blood pressure generated by your heart within these,
within this tuft of capillaries,
this blood is pressurized,
right?
It's pressurized because it's not that far from your heart,
There's not that much resistance between where pressures formed in your heart.
And this tough in the sack outside is a low pressure.
Now this is a different kind of a pressure drop because we'd been thinking about
a pressure drop along a tube,
right?
High pressure here,
low pressure here.
So fluid flows through the tube instead.
Now we have high pressure inside of a Tuft of capillaries and low pressure
outside.
So the pressure drop is not along the tube.
It's across the wall of the tube.
And if there's a pressure drop across the wall of the tube and the wall is
leaky,
then water can move across.
So it moves from inside the tube outside.
High pressure inside the tube,
low pressure outside.
This is where the filtration function of the kidney takes place in the
capillaries of the glove.
Mary and the capillaries of the glomerulus are leaky there holes in them.
And so if there's high pressure on the inside,
low pressure on the outside fluid can flow through and anything that's small
enough to fit through these holes can pass through with the
okay.
And so that,
that hundred liters per day that's filtered occurs in these 1 million,
uh,
go marry a lie of the 1 million nephrons in each kidney.
This space that's in this sack here is where the first differences between urine
and plasma are created,
right?
Because the fluid that accumulates in this sack outside the Glen Maria lists by
filtration is different from plasma.
It's different from plasma.
In what way?
Well,
it only has molecules that are small enough to pass through the filter.
And so it only has molecules that are below a certain size.
So plasma has blood cells,
has red blood cells,
has white blood cells.
It has proteins,
glucose ions,
but the urine only has things that are smaller than a certain size.
So imagine a cutoff in molecular weight and everything that's below that is
present.
Everything that's above it is not present.
How does the concentration of sodium in the glomerulus compared to the
concentration of sodium in this space in this want to be urine space?
Well,
the concentrations the same at this point because what you have here is just to
filtrate and if the molecule is very small like water or like sodium,
then all the molecules are going to pass through.
There won't be any difference in concentration on either side of the filter.
Okay.
So what does this fluid look like at this point of the tube of the beginning of
the urine flow pathway?
It looks like what's called an ultra filtrate of plasma.
It looks like plasma,
but with just the big molecules,
the big stuff removed,
the concentration of everything else would be the same.
That makes sense.
So after filtration,
this fluid passes through this,
uh,
through this winding set of tubes,
these whining set of tubules.
Now these are called the kidney tubules.
This is not blood that's flowing through here now,
but this is the fluid that wants to be urine and it flows through.
And the,
these tubules in the kidney are divided into segments.
The first segment is called the proximal convoluted tubule.
It's called convoluted because it twists around its proximal because proximal
means near.
And this part of the tube is near the goal.
Mary Alice proximal convoluted tubule.
The fluid flows through it.
Fluid flows down this loop and this loop extends from the top near the cortex of
the kidney down toward them,
the dollar and then up again,
right,
there's a loop.
And this loop is called the loop of Henley,
H,
e n,
l,
e,
after,
um,
an anatomist who uh,
who described it first.
So it's called the loop of Henley.
And then there's another region here,
which is another twisting,
winding tubule,
another convoluted tubule,
but it's far from the Golem aerialist.
So this is called the distal convoluted tubule.
And then finally that distal convoluted tubule flows into a straight duct that
goes down through the mandala called the collecting duct.
And this collecting duct dumps directly into the ureter,
which carries urine to the bladder.
So there's a lot of action here,
right,
that the,
uh,
an ultra filtrate of plasma is formed in this space.
This space,
by the way,
is called Bowman's space.
After another anatomist who first discovered it,
the space where the filtration occurs into is called Bowman's space.
Uh,
the urine flows through the distal convoluted tubule through the loop of Henley,
I'm sorry,
through the proximal convoluted tubule,
down the loop of Henley,
backup the loop of Henley through the distal proximal distal convoluted tubule
into the collecting duct and then out to the ureter and the bladder.
Now what's happening?
Why this,
why this complicated series of tubes arranged in this way and it,
and actually if we looked at the,
uh,
the,
the microscopic anatomy in each of these tubes,
that's what's shown here is what do the cells look like that form these tubes at
different regions of the nephron.
And one thing that you could notice and that anatomist noticed when they started
studying the kidney is that these tubes all look are,
these tubes are all composed of cells that look slightly different.
And the reason that they look slightly different is because they're performing
different functions.
And uh,
the details are the functions that they're performing are beyond the scope of
what we're going to talk about it you'll be responsible for.
I'll mention a few of them,
but one way to think about it is that different parts of the tubule have
different functions in terms of reabsorption of molecules from the urine.
That the main task of the nephron after this filtration step is to recover the
things that the body is still needs to recover.
Sodium,
to recover glucose,
to recover a potassium,
and to recover most importantly water.
So that you don't have to be drinking constantly in order to remain healthy and
different parts of the tubule are responsible for different elements of that
reabsorption process.
It turns out it's not quite so simple as that.
You couldn't say glucose is here,
sodiums here,
potassium's here.
It's not quite that separated.
But they function in sort of a coordination in order to accomplish this overall
process with each part of the tubule performing slightly different functions to
do that.
Here's the picture that I promised earlier,
why just wanted to show you what I've been showing you.
The kidney turned on its side,
so here you'd be laying down on your side,
I guess in the abdominal aorta is coming down here.
Blood flowing up to this kidney.
Uh,
here's the,
um,
the capsule,
here's the Mandala and here's all the nephrons arranged in this up and down a
pattern along the breadth of the,
of the kidney.
And,
um,
this just shows that there are glow marea lie these small Tufts everywhere
throughout the,
this upper region of the,
of the kidney that there are,
that all of these glow Mary lie our branches of a branch of the renal artery and
that,
uh,
nephrons,
you could see in that cartoon I showed you before.
Uh,
here's one nephron shown.
Here's the Glomerulus list and here's the proximal convoluted tubule.
And you can see in this more elaborate drawing just how convoluted it is that
there are many,
many,
these are quite long tubules.
Uh,
so there's a long pathway for fluid to flow through and that's in order to give
the kidney cells time to perform this,
uh,
this function on all of the fluid that is flowing through the kidney.
This is kind of a complicated picture and I'll let you look at it at your
leisure.
These are posted on the classes server.
What I want to show you mainly as this figure down here,
and this is a picture of the filter in the kidney.
Now where does the filter reside in the kidney?
It's at the it,
it's the capillaries.
It's the walls of these capillaries that formed these Tufts in the GL,
Mary Alice.
And this picture is a scanning electron micrograph that was taken by,
uh,
by taking one of these capillaries,
cutting it open and then spreading it out so you could look down on the surface.
So here we're like looking from the,
actually from the outside of the tube in and what you see is holes
and these are physical holes that are of a size that allows small molecules to
pass through and but keep blood cells and large molecules on the other side.
And so the kidney really is a filter in an important sense and it functions just
like a coffee filter or any of the synthetic filters you might use,
which are just mainly made of materials that have many small holes in them,
right?
And that's what this,
uh,
this,
tubule looks like.
So there is a filtration of function in order to perform this filtration
functionality mentioned that you need to have pressure,
right?
You got to have a pressure drop in order to filter and that pressure drop is
generated by the heart.
But here's an interesting thing.
We look,
we talked about pressure drop in the circulation.
Remember when we talked,
uh,
before spring break
about where is the main resistance to pressure or to flow along the vessels of
your cardiovascular system?
Pressures generated by the heart.
If we think about the left side of the heart,
blood flows into the aorta,
into large arteries,
arterials,
capillaries.
That's where exchange takes place back into venules,
veins,
back to the heart.
Where was the main pressure drop?
The main source of resistance,
which,
which one of those elements had the largest resistance?
Do you remember
somebody's Brian?
Did you
perfect?
The capillaries have a sizable resistance but not the most.
And,
and,
and it is important because it's the place where your number size is regulated
so that you can adjust flow rates most sensitively here in the arterials are the
small arteries.
And it turns out that the glomerular capillaries are the capillaries of these
Tufts sit in a unique position between two sets of arterials,
arterial that leads into the next,
into the glomerulus and an arterial that leads out of the Glomerulus.
And because of that,
if you have this tuft of capillaries that sitting on either side of an arterial,
now what did arterials do?
They were the right size,
the right physical dimension,
so that they created a fairly substantial resistance to flow.
That's one thing.
They're the right size to create a fairly substantial resistance to flow and
they can expand and contract and so they can adjust their resistance and what
happens when they adjust their resistance,
they change the overall pressure drop for that segment.
And by changing the pressure drop,
you can change how much flow occurs,
right?
Well,
the glomerular capillaries sit here between two arterioles and they can
independently regulate their size and what that allows the individual nephron to
do is to adjust.
What's the pressure inside?
It's glomerular capillaries.
If I want the pressure to be lower,
then I squeeze in on this one,
the one that's leading in,
I get more of a pressure drop across that arterial,
so the pressure's lower coming out.
If I want the higher pressure drop on the glomerular capillaries,
I expand this so that I don't have as much resistance.
I don't have as much of a pressure drop.
I have higher pressure in the glomerular capillaries.
Now,
why would that make a difference?
Because remember these glomerular capillaries sit inside this capsule where
there's a low pressure.
If I have a pressure here,
low pressure here,
I get filtration.
If pressure goes up inside here,
but stays the same out here,
I get more filtration.
Pressure goes down,
I get less.
So every individual nephron has a mechanism for regulating how much fluid it
filters at any particular time.
And it does that by regulating the arteries on either side of the culinary alert
Tuft.
Okay.
I'm going to stop there and then we'll continue next time talking a little bit
more detail about how the,
uh,
how the kidneys do this task of recovering molecules that you need
questions.
Good.
See you on Thursday.